at what point did Mountain Dew become
like white trash thing like cuz well
when I was a kid maybe just cuz I was
white trash you just beat me to it damn
it but I don't remember anybody talking
but that I I grew up in a very again
white trash town oh [__] when when did
hitting your wife become white trash
when the hell was when did not giving
your wife a nice backhand but when you
were a kid would did people talk about
Mountain Dew there was definitely
Mountain Dew around but I do feel like
even for us that a bit of a white
connotation I also think that it was It
was kind of in that of like cool radical
Kid Zone soda was like The Last of the
Mohicans of like you know cigarettes and
like [__] and [__] like that it was like
the last surviving thing that was
clearly bad for children that you could
just be like drink three of these a day
and you'll be cool like Tony Hawk once
there was probably regulation that was
like you can't do this to Children
anymore that's when it became like well
now the only kids drinking Mountain Dew
are white trash